this presentation is delivered by the
stanford center for professional
development
good afternoon and welcome to our final
lecture in this quarter of
engineering and climate change i have
really enjoyed this
i i thank you for being such good
students
um now that we're here i hope we've
provided you with a start on what you
need to know to go out and make your own
impact in the world with some really
real and
well considered contributions to the
challenges
brought by climate change i think this
will be the
issue of your careers if you choose to
take this
on and keep in touch you've got my email
i'll put it up again right at the end of
class too
i would love to hear about what if you
have climate-related
adventures to share i would love to hear
them
um as you know we've covered a lot of
ground and today
we're focusing on ice as one of our
big deals i want to get my mouse here so
i can point to things
yes so here we are we've seen the tip of
the iceberg we will
continue from there and
we've had a phenomenal array of lectures
i am struck
every time i teach this the generosity
with which people with
astounding backgrounds and astoundingly
busy schedules
come here so they can share what they
know with all of us
it's that's a very generous thing on
their part and
i'm amazed time after time so today
we're going to talk about
of course wrap up engineering climate
deliberately engineering climate um my
own
research project in that area and just
any
wrap up you've got um that we need to do
so here's how to reach me
my stanford address here the class
lecture summaries are giving me the
attendance they're what i
grade you on for this past no pass if
we'll get into more of that in a second
and the videos will stay up through scpd
for through the end of the quarter
however they define that
so the end of this week certainly
probably the end of next week
and beyond that i think they're going on
youtube so if you
need to catch up on anything i would try
to do it by the end of this week
and thanks to those who did meet over
lunch sometimes for the
office hour before class that was that
was fun
um an occasional thing a nice treat when
it happened
so for your homework for today
please submit the summary for this
lecture
and any missing lecture summaries by
monday so i can go ahead and submit
grades
i assume you want them soon just so you
wrap up and make sure you passed and all
that
if you still have more than one missing
summary
by friday night i'll send you an email
over the weekend
to remind you and my requirement is
you just need to turn in nine out of the
ten summaries so if you're missing one
especially if you missed the will chua
one
which then got taken off the site you
know
i'm certainly not going to give you a
problem about that
and if you're missing some of the
questions for the lecturers stress not
the idea of that really was to get much
better interaction going with the
lecturers
and if you got them in and a lot of you
did really thoughtful questions that
really helped inspire the lecturers so i
appreciate it and i appreciate the ones
that i've gotten to see too as of about
9 9 30 this morning i could see all the
ones that you'd sent and
it let me know some of what you wanted
to cover so thank you for that but if
you're missing them
don't worry you will not flunk the
course from that
but those who did you made it better for
all of us it was great
readings for next week of course none so
good luck with finals um this is one
class where you get to wrap it up pretty
quick
um okay
if you would like to have it strikes me
you might like to have a class
alumni email list going
so that you can keep on doing climate
related discussions with each other
or with me let me know and i'll put
those who want to do that
in touch with each other feed you each
other's email addresses but if this is
not of interest
don't worry there's no requirement at
all and i won't automatically put you on
a list
this goes for our auditors too if you
guys want to be in on a
discussion just send me an email that
you'd like to do that
and then the same information
opportunities that we've been showing
before
at stanford and nearby we got a new one
from hazy i think this is
a little different way of looking at the
energy seminars here
through the featured video so that's
nice this agu meeting is going on this
week up in san francisco i have heard
that there are nearly 30
000 earth scientists etc up there in
attendance i
i went to the icebreaker reception on
sunday night it was
oh one word so there's a lot of people
up there and a lot of them are obsessing
about ice which you'll hear about today
there's student rates if any of you can
get away i think the student rate for a
one day pass is pretty minimal
and it's up in the moscone center so
that's one way to get up to speed on a
lot
and then there have been a lot i'll put
this on the site too so you don't have
to frantically be writing this down
but a lot of you have sent some really
great suggestions lately
on some interesting things to be looking
at
so we'll go ahead and have those on
there a bunch
and there are some proposed lectures for
next time
i appreciate that um we we always want
to grow
our our uh roster of terrific lecturers
to have in here
um you're welcome to take the class
again for credit i believe it's
permitted
but there will probably be some lectures
the same and
the plan is to teach it every fall i got
to see as part of the kickoff for the
agu meeting this
phenomenal documentary chasing ice it is
remarkable
it's remarkably beautiful it's
remarkably disturbing
this this cinematographer who used to be
a scientist and
consorts with a lot of really experts in
ice
has roamed around the planet placing
cameras with
timed photos and has collected years
worth of data now
on many retreating and collapsing
glaciers and it is beautiful
they do it as a human interest story as
well
it's remarkable and it's only in
theaters for a short while
so take a look at that and
follow up if you're interested in that i
i would say if you're
concerned about climate you've really
got to see this film
um this is from ken caldera who gave the
geo engineering lecture the first time i
taught this class and you'll see some of
his slides interspersed
there's online discussion groups
specifically about geoengineering if you
find that of interest
and here's a few photos from the chasing
ice trailer
a truly remarkable film i think the
closest one right now is at the
embarcadero up in san francisco
but you can sign pledges online that you
will go see it things like that to help
it stay in theaters for a little longer
so this week's guest lecturer it is i um
and no surprise there and
i thought i saw faces last week when i
started to go over my
background that looked interested and
some of the questions
sounded interested so i
basically i am a person who's done a
couple fields of engineering and
been very happily at work trying to
increase the efficiency with which we
were using
our oil resources and then
going ahead and using mems micro
electromechanical systems for all kinds
of things consumer products
health these days a lot into the health
care
area in my consulting practice my
consulting practice
by the way was founded we started out
with mostly women
which is quite a change from those old
days when i was at mit
i was there in the era of 10 women
undergrad
and to be able to have in my consulting
company of about
16 of us working together have mostly
women yeah think how weird the dynamics
are
as at least as weird as you think when
it's just 10
women of the undergrads on campus and
then the graduate population was far
less
strange times um things have certainly
gotten a lot more balanced since but now
in my consulting company we are over
half women
and in the management positions um very
much
women so it's it's a different world um
so an engineer deep engineer by
background who has become obsessed
with climate that is what i call my
inconvenient hobby for the last six and
a half years or so
so what happened you'll you'll get to
hear a little bit of that but i decided
that was
the key question of our our age
especially fueled by having kids which
is what also fueled my getting into
consulting
you know how do you make room for that
and how do you plan for their future and
add to your to-do list of all the things
you worry about you know
getting them through college all of that
to add habitable planet
matters so that's uh that's sort of
the short story of how on earth did i
get into this
so let's start talking about some of
these slides you'll see from the first
lecture that we gave the the
introduction to this where i spoke about
what is the climate problem and then we
had that wonderful excerpt from terry
root
who sends her greetings but just could
not come this quarter
but uh if you ever want to talk to her
send her questions or something i'm sure
she would talk to you she's phenomenal
so this was the earth's energy balance
beautiful
slide just detailing there's a lot of
energy coming in
some gets reflected here there there's
this whole water cycle going on with its
own energetics
there's energy absorbed by the
atmosphere and then there's this whole
interaction that's happening
with the greenhouse gases and the
re-radiation
and that's in a very beautiful nutshell
what earth's energy balance looks like
another way to think about it is that
what's as we're changing our atmosphere
as we're running this
unprecedented experiment on what our
atmospheric gas composition is
we're changing the set point we're
changing that equilibrium value here
and we've changed it move the set point
up
and so this i showed this also the first
time we'll go over the old stuff
pretty quick um that we have
actually got our co2 concentration
from what it's been over the last 400
000 years you can see up here
we've spiked it now we've spiked it in a
way that we haven't seen before and
people get this kind of data from ice
cores things like that
and so it's it's good data and we're in
an unprecedented spot so what on earth
do we do about it
you've seen also that the experts are
saying here's another ken caldera slide
that the temperatures are continuing to
increase throughout this century in
every plausible emission scenario we see
no practical way to reduce temperatures
in this century is what they say so what
do we do here's the motivation for
looking into geoengineering solutions
and frankly looking into them before our
backs into the wall
because the last thing you want to do is
to end up in a situation where you say
our temperature is rising we're seeing
our species becoming extinct faster and
faster rate let's do something now
and not have studied it and not have
considered the consequences
so people like ken are looking people
like me
are looking at solutions we hope in
advance of when they might be needed so
that people don't
get tempted to take rash in sudden
action
and here we are again all of these
scenarios that people have made
we we tend to exceed the worst the most
pessimistic scenario
that has been made so these are
right here we are putting in the
2005-2006 numbers it just keeps
getting worse and so preventing any
further warming requires near zero
emissions
but in fact you know the co2 level
that's already in the atmosphere is
predicted to
that it will raise uh our temperature
global
earth average by a couple degrees c now
so this is pretty bad and what does this
mean what are the probabilities this was
the last time i looked at the
mit wheel of misfortune here and
you know the chances look absolutely
excellent
that we're at least in for three or four
degrees c increase
and that looks like we might be lucky
and that's just in a few short years
that the scenarios change to that
because we keep exceeding
the worst scenario people have said and
why do we care
here's the one that motivates me a lot
is this extinction
the same thing terry root was talking
about the mass extinction of species
but as as you look at this site this was
put together this slide this was put
together
from the ipcc i think the 2007
assessment report
there's really a lot of really quite
dreadful
things that happen so what do we do well
one thing i do i've got to say
some of you asked why i got into
teaching you know anything i can do
in the rest of my working career i think
pales
in comparison with getting some
brilliant students
motivated and educated in the right
areas
so that you folks can educate yourselves
the rest of the way and take this on
right you're much earlier in your
careers and there are many more of you
and this is this is the hope because
this is a
dreadful problem you've been handed and
um you know there are there are a couple
choices
um one choice is this right
which is just feeling ah the mack truck
is coming
this this frankly is how i felt after i
watched the inconvenient truth movie
um standing between the mack truck and
the little kid
the innocent kid who doesn't deserve
this um
and i don't like feeling paralyzed but
positive action i find helps a lot
so what are we concerned about we're
concerned about all the things you hear
about on the news
right ocean temperatures and sea levels
are rising now back in 2007
it was still the deal that the ocean
temperatures were what was mainly
responsible for the sea levels rising
just thermal expansion
but these last few years enough ice has
melted
that isn't wasn't already floating in
the ocean which doesn't do much for
sea level but enough has melted and
added to
the overall inventory there that the sea
levels
are rising in large part because of that
as well which is a big deal and i was
just talking to somebody at the agu
conference on sunday night who was
saying chesapeake bay they're up 17
inches already
that's not the worldwide average but
different circulation patterns
golf currents and such some areas are
getting it far
more quickly already 17 inches the earth
size coverage is shrinking
you've certainly heard that and it's
it's amazing
in the suddenness to which it's
accelerated and this
all serves to shift weather patterns so
if you're trying to grow crops
if you're trying to have enough drinking
water if you're trying to live
this will affect you and of course
critters
are taking it in the teeth too right um
very much that's that's that whole
extinction
scenario so not a pretty thing
and we could get stuck there we really
could get stuck
just saying oh this is horrible but
frankly that's
no great place to live so let's see what
we can do
and so again some of you seemed
interested in this this is why i will
tell you one woman's journey um
but moving past paralysis i really
thought what on earth in this whole
thing can i grab onto
and i'm hoping this survey course has
given you all
enough i mean a lot of you came in with
a lot of expertise already so
you probably already know what you want
to grab onto but if you didn't
just what part of this do you want to
grab onto to try to do something
about and to me it was well what about
an environmentally benign removable
artificial ice cap
to help rebuild ice and snow help tip
the balance back because ice is big deal
and you know i i have a certain amount
of perspective at my time of career
so my first spreadsheet on the project i
called global crazy idea
right because what are the chances never
guess i see the appreciation there
because what are the chances that a
person not trained in this area
you know one of six billion people not a
climate scientist is going well over six
billion people is going to come up with
an idea that will do any good after all
you know persistence and you guys
probably all have a lot of persistence
and a lot of intelligence to be
here right um has you well
can i figure something out i don't need
to give up right away let's just
keep working on that and getting expert
advice so
steve schneider and terry root thank
goodness i got to take their
summer course i got to talk with them
and i got some key encouragement of no
this isn't nuts go try it
and then gsip right you've got so many
wonderful resources right in your
backyard here at stanford
and then went ahead why would you file a
patent application on this stuff
because i've been in technology long
enough to know that you can't decide not
to
and then a year or two later after
you've published scope i should have
patent law will not let you do that so
if you think you might want to protect
it and you think you might commercialize
someday go ahead and do it
so it's that reflex you can't put the
genie back in the bottle
so that's that's kind of how i got in
and it was really that feeling
led to let's start thinking about
something concrete and see how far we
can get
frankly you know if the main thing that
comes out of my
particular six and a half years at this
point working on trying to slow down ice
melt if the main thing
is that one of you says that's nice so
i love her idealism but i've got a far
better idea
yes that's a win right because
that's a win um so what's important to
look at here
if you wanted we've got a lot of slides
with a lot of words coming here
about climate but what are we really
after
well the key problems seem to be stop
the increase
of co2 at least let's not let it get any
worse
and so the ongoing co2 emissions levels
need to be reduced and so everything
we've been learning about electric
cars about liquid fuels you know better
building just the whole sequence that we
have learned in this class of various
things people are worrying about
they're all so important and we've got
to not increase
our methane levels which are a worse a
more powerful
greenhouse gas than co2 is as well so
we've got two things we got to keep our
eye on the prize there
and that's conservation alternative
energy sources all the
lists that that's very familiar to us
furthermore
if we can we've got to bring the levels
down
if we could do some of the carbon
sequestration methods that people look
into
to bring the levels down that are in the
atmosphere
or down in the ocean where the ocean
acidification is killing
a lot of the marine life um that would
be huge too
so there are very important things not
mutually exclusive we need to
bring everything to the game type of
approach
and in the meantime this is leslie
looking at all of this going
that's great we need to do it but it
might not be fast enough that's
when you start thinking about
geoengineering so what are the band-aids
in the meantime
and believe me probably more than most
of you
i'm guessing the moral repugnance of
getting into that
it's just it's like golly i think we
need it but i don't even
want to know i'm working on it was my
feeling of the first few years on this
because it really is talk about hubris
the kind of
stuff that got us in here in the first
place of man can do no wrong and there
will be no
impacts but sometimes you have to
consider unpleasant things
and so let me make this plea i hope
you've looked at
or can look at a life the lca lecture
that's on
on the site as well uh on the material
site the life cycle analysis you know
any framework you have to try to
consider as many implications as
possible
of what you do are going to be very key
especially
i think if you're going to start trying
to muck with planetary band-aids
so here in the more formal sense you
know
here are our choices right as we talked
about earlier in the quarter mitigation
adaptation and geoengineering and by
mitigation it's the conservation energy
efficiency all of that
the adaptation are things like coral new
york city right suddenly realizing
we are really going to have to do some
vast re-engineering
as far as sea level rise and major
storms go wow
and then the geo engineering so the
motivation here is possible emergency
backup
if all else fails but got to do the
research in advance you're not going to
do it while they're pointing the gun to
your head of
we're going up another two degrees and
the moral hazard
what has become very clear is that
people who tend to be
climate deniers will apparently
often take from that standpoint of oh
there isn't a problem
the observation is that they will
quickly if they are presented with an
attractive sounding geoengineering
solution say
ah but we can solve it with that if
there is so there's this moral hazard of
let's not
change our ways let's not change our
energy mix let's just
keep on the path that we were on and
there's a fix
already for us and so there's a real
problem
with counting on this one should never
ever
think that geo engineering will solve it
all and not do all those other necessary
things we need to do in the mitigation
in the adaptation
so here are again courtesy of ken
caldera some of the ways that you can
look at saying how do we
stabilize the climate here's our end
goal well diminish the end use energy
demand
produce the energy without carbon
emission remove
the greenhouse gases from the atmosphere
or reduce the amount of solar radiation
absorbed
and a lot a lot a lot of people are
looking on this end of things
in various ways of reducing they call it
solar radiation management srm
and that's that's a focus for a lot and
so
here's another way from this book oh
this was from the royal society geo
engineering report but there's also
engineering response to global climate
change this book by
robert g watt very good summary
and in fact if anybody is a parting shot
wants to borrow this because they don't
have a lot of finals
and make an arrangement to get it back
to me sometime this is a good one
okay i don't see a lot you guys all have
classes
that's a good one and so here are
two ways of looking at it again i think
we have to bring everything to the game
but carbon dioxide removal techniques
vastly important and solar radiation
management techniques
a lot of people looking at that
and so there are different categories of
this you can make a deep study of this
we don't have time to make a deep study
of this but um just know that it's there
so that you have enough information you
can dig in deeper
and a lot of what gsep does is looking
at these carbon dioxide
removal techniques so there's a lot of
expertise
in-house here
basically what are we going to do with
it are we going to collect it are we
going to put it into the ocean
it's are we going to put it into trees
what's our capacity to do that
you can see that and these
carbon reservoirs in the earth these are
copied out of this book
are huge and some of it people don't
quite understand
so there are temperature and co2
responses that we don't quite
understand that we suspect the ocean is
taking up more than our models indicate
it should
or should that we're fortunate there but
if you don't understand why it's going
there
you don't quite understand when it's
going to come back out either so there
are some
worries about all of this but you can
get an
in order of magnitude of how much is
this carbon exchange going on what are
the magnitudes here if you wanted to
approach something
you know the numbers exist so you can
see what's the order of magnitude on
what you want to do
and there are you know human beings are
a creative bunch
we really are and there are
a lot of proposals that you and you can
find things this was from technology
review
you can you could this is from the new
york times you can just see an
astonishing array of things people are
proposing
and some of them look like they'd work
and some of them look like they would
have
enormous side consequences few of them
address the acidification of the ocean
which is
huge other problem with all of this some
of them
amuse me this was this was orbiting
trillions of teeny sun shades up in the
upper atmosphere
and oh my goodness the carbon
impact of launching all of these the how
would you ever
bring them out the you know get them
back down and when you decided this was
a bad idea because you killed the
crop yield area of you know vast parts
of the
planet is one potential it seems to me
i'm not an expert on this one but this
one strikes me as
a a good example to always be sure to
include
um and at all but you know but you
understand right it's like okay if we're
getting too hot
we'll put up an umbrella basically and
we'll make it better
okay i appreciate simple thinking i
really do
um i try to engage in it whenever
possible because the really great ideas
come from that actually like that solar
light bulb right that we saw earlier in
the quarter
and yet geo engineering involves really
complex issues and that was a good
example
of it because there could be unintended
consequences what about crop yields what
about political destabilization because
my country's better off than yours
because of that
i think we'd better go to war over it
you know there's some really bad things
that could happen
and if it's irreversible heavens if what
you're doing is irreversible or not
easily reversible
remember that example terry roothead in
that snippet we showed of introducing
one new population to take care of the
last one that
there was an unintended consequence
let's introduce another one
this is all so complex and are we going
to get it right the first time
i wouldn't guarantee that and the
estimates of
how it's going to work depend on lots of
assumptions and on climate models which
is i understand at the granularity with
which you can run the climate models
is not great enough to really get all
the information out that people
wish to get and the governance heavens
some of you asked
such an excellent question some of you
were asking who decides
if you're doing a geo engineering thing
who decides where that goes
shouldn't there be a policy oh yeah
there should and what's the public
acceptance beyond that
you know okay in principle golly i've
seen towns around here
go go nuts over should there be
affordable housing you know which is
still what
over a million dollars but should there
be affordable housing
of course there should but maybe not in
my backyard is what people
well would you think perhaps you'd get
the same kind of
reaction about any geoengineering
techniques as well
great but not here so it's uh there's a
lot of human nature in all of this
and there are a range of strategies
people talk about here's a ken caldera
slide
and one that he has been talking about
for
a number of years as really looking
promising because it's inexpensive
because you can deploy it rapidly
as this whole concept of stratospheric
dust sulfate aerosol injections in the
troposphere
is one um technique that a lot of
people have gotten behind really wanting
to do about a dozen
academics that i know of are really
seriously looking at that saying you
know it's like a volcano
if you've got a volcanic eruption and
you've got a big
emission of ash and so2 and such
you will lower your temperature so
that's good so that's what we want to do
right
well pinatubo
1991 they could see the results of this
it really did work and there's a lot of
options
to get aerosols in the stratosphere and
i have been in a meeting earlier this
year where a couple different airplane
companies were in this meeting
talking about how it would cost about a
billion dollars you could do it with
this kind of aircraft or this kind of
aircraft but you could do it
but my gosh do we understand that well
enough
do we really want to put that out there
do we know what the prevailing winds
will be who will be most effective what
will happen in rainfall patterns
so big concern and it's got people
having convening
policy meetings and such about what
shall we do about this
so and that iron flinger um
is what i call him uh the fellow who
wants to
seed phytoplankton growth in the ocean
by putting
iron in has just started doing things
without
any real permission he got permission
from a local fishing village to
dump a couple tons of iron and he got
paid for it
with the thought that these these guys
would get paid back
by carbon credits eventually the last
workshop i went to on
soft geo engineering a few weeks ago in
washington people were talking about
that because he had done this just
before that workshop
and and he had i hadn't realized that he
had
promised them money from carbon credits
and
that that will never happen what what
was their motivation on paying him for
this
to bring back their fish population so
that they could go ahead and keep on
making their living fishing
interesting stuff is being contemplated
and the policy whoever was asking about
the policy and i'm sure a lot of you
were thinking about it too
it's key and it's got to be intelligent
because on the other hand you might need
some kinds of geoengineering
and you might not want to stop all
small-scale experiments from being able
to go ahead because
our backs may be against the wall
and so here is another ken caldera
slide reflection of sunlight can offsa
set most climate change in most places
most of the time
well when i read this i think he's
thinking about temperature
he is not thinking about ocean
acidification but he's thinking about
temperature and temperature is really
important
and he has some slides that he he knows
how disturbing these concepts are his
his whole point is do the research now
so we don't
do something stupid later um but
this is really striking the idea of this
is what if
you have surface air temperature rising
rising
you know this is a model and what if you
turn on
and in this case turning on geo
engineering i'm pretty sure he means the
stratospheric sulfate aerosol injections
you can cool things pretty quick that's
the appeal
that's why people really keep looking at
this option
because no matter how bad it gets you
might be able to
cool it quick quickly but here is
one of the really vicious things about
it and that is
that when you turn it back off let's say
you decided there was some horrible
consequence and you wanted to give the
earth's atmosphere a few years to clean
this back out and go back the way it was
because heavens this unintended
consequence is just killing us
the problem is that the temperature rise
is quicker once you turn it off going
back to the original curve
pretty much or approximating the
original curve more quickly than it
would have in the first place
which as we learned from terry root
leads to even more
species extinction rapid changes all in
one direction are what are one of the
key things that drive species extinction
no time to adapt
so once you're in uh sorry once you're
in
sorry once you're in to this kind of
let's make a modification
you're in you know if there will be
consequences to stopping
so that's a grave thing to consider as
well so here we are
looking at these three that we just
talked about the mitigation
the adaptation got to do it the
geoengineering
rationale of why we do it and then here
comes
what i've been working on for a few
years which has now been called soft
geoengineering steve schneider when i
first
showed him and terry root about this
dubbed at ecoengineering
the whole point of this is and it's
motivated
in fair part by thinking about some of
these irreversible things people think
about
is you really would like to have
something that was reversible
or removable in case you mess up in case
there's an unintended consequence
because heaven knows most of the time
there is
and to have it be local and small
so that you're having a local ecological
impact you want to minimize what you're
doing you want to try to rebuild a
natural process as much as you can
rather than try to provoke some you know
often some different world
to try to keep things stabilized in kind
of the way that we're used to in the way
that we evolved with in the way all
these
the life on this earth evolved and so
the idea here
is just how do you how do you
do that in a way that's environmentally
respectful it's not going to have much
impact so think about the backpackers
philosophy of leap no trace or the
doctor's philosophy of first do no harm
and that's really what trying to do but
and so i started this in 2006 today it's
all been volunteer
and that's partly because of the
realities of funding and partly
because if you don't have if your only
economic
outcome from doing something is that
it's taking your time away from your
kids and your paying job it may keep you
away from a conflict of interest
of saying i got to do this because i'm
going to get rich from it
it may but it also means things go
slowly
and so i've got to say the slowly part
is beginning to drive me nuts because
things have gone so much more
quickly recently that positive feedback
loop
of ice melting has accelerated so much
this
oh gosh you know is it is it too late to
do anything
and so these recent reports this this
chasing ice movie
it's like god things are pretty dire so
here we are so how are we doing this
um we've covered a lot of this basically
what we're trying to do is relatively
inexpensive and local
first do no harm i've shown you this ice
chart before i think this is just
through 2007
but the ice melt in 2012 was
far worse this is all
way off the curve of what the ipcc
projections were these were all the ipcc
projections of here's the range of what
we think might happen
if you can't read these this is from
1960 here to 2080 here
we're about here this was the 2007 ice
melt
and the red is kind of the average of
all of those projections
and on 2007 we fell off the cliff but if
you look at it carefully
you will see actually this change in
slope
and this is what don perovich a
long-time ice expert
decades of expertise got to counsel me
about a few years ago when i went to
visit him in his lab
we get to speak again actually tomorrow
at the agu meeting and it will be good
to catch up
i've just no surprise if you've been
studying ice for decades you've watched
this
happening but to this degree
wow and so dramatic ice melt blows away
previous
record just wow
so they're talking about when i first
got into this 50
000 square kilometers per year summer to
summer ice melt was kind of the typical
thing
in the peter wadhams book which i also
recommend if you decide to share my
obsession with ice
ice in the ocean peter wadham's
phenomenal book
that was the number that was kind of
typical of the decade leaving
leading up to 2000 but now they're
talking about
a million a million what's the
were the numbers banding about um
recently from this
last year's ice melt from this year's
ice melt so 20 times as bad
it's just phenomenal and it has dramatic
impact all over
climate because the arctic ocean is four
percent of the world's
ocean area it's it's it's changing the
oceanic currents
sea level rise rainfall patterns species
and habitat disruption
and why is this happening this is
something called the ice albedo feedback
effect climate scientists have been
saying that this is about 20 this
contributes about 20
to the global rate of warming i'm
suspecting
with it having accelerated so much
lately that it may be far worse
but the the mechanism is simply that the
more ice you're melting
the more open ocean area you have
and remember ice will reflect you know
it's just as simple as albedo is
reflecting right ice will reflect about
night
multi-year ice old ice with a lot of air
in it
will reflect back about 90 percent
rough numbers of the sunlight coming
into it but open ocean like this black
desk here or
this black cover here will absorb
more like 90 so there's a huge
difference in how much energy
is getting absorbed and that's that's
what drives this mechanism
of this ever shrinking little piece of
ice in the middle
so drastic stuff so what am i thinking
about i'm thinking about just using
floating
removable or being able to reverse the
effect materials to change the albedo
but to allow evaporation people talk
about you know there's a lot of people
whose reflex and you might have seen it
on the geo engineering sort of survey
slide there
of some of the photos of things people
are thinking about
if you just coat things with plastic
that's easy we know how to coat stuff
with plastic
it doesn't work so well because you're
suppressing evaporation
basically if you think about your pool
cover you're basically remaking your
pool cover
although maybe a light color instead of
a dark cover so you don't want to do
that
so one of the things i wanted to be sure
to do is to allow evaporation allow
evaporative cooling
in anything that we do and you want to
be able to reverse this if you're over
compensating
or if your predictions are incomplete
one thing that might be the particularly
sweet spot
to do this is to try to protect glaciers
glaciers have a mechanism where they the
ice and snow on top start melting and
they stop start forming these
melt pools and these melt
pools these lakes can become so big and
so heavy
that the pressure from them helps to
tunnel through and through a crack below
you can actually form and widen cracks
and that lubricates the slide of great
chunks of the ice sheet
off into the ocean now you've raised
your
your sea levels again and here's a
recent picture this is one of
i think this no this is from somebody
from university of manchester but you've
got similar
um photos from that chasing ice film as
well
and it's just dramatic when the ice when
the water the melt water starts flowing
off it's dramatic what's going on
you could also think about um trying to
make
some artificial ice caps thick enough
you don't want to do this from a cause
standpoint if you're going to cover a
fair chunk of the ocean
or or near shore area but if you want it
in selected areas for where the polar
bears are still left for breeding
habitat
you could make some areas that are
thicker and and just
basically thicker artificial ice to
allow them
uh some wildlife pullouts and these are
very rough
estimates you know a cent per square
meter
one of the raw materials i really love
for this sort of thing
and you know maybe a few thousand
dollars for a polar bear pull out just
for the materials to actually get things
placed to get them there to get them
contained in a way that you'd be able to
undo it
will add cost no doubt and what does
that mean
that means that lovely energy balance
diagram that i like so much
we're trying to modify things in a few
different ways
i'm trying to modify the reflectivity
trying
not to mess up this whole latent heat
cycle and we're trying
not to mess up anything here you know
allow
allow cooling back radiation overnight
as well
and as an engineer i love the idea
that if we think of co2 or temperature
is being
uncontrolled here and if we think about
maybe darkening the earth with one of
these
you know global srm techniques
where we might over correct and drive
ourselves to the next ice age
that maybe if we're doing something that
we can modulate
you know maybe if we decide it's too
much trouble to pull these artificial
ice caps off but we
golly we're good at soot you know we
could scatter some soot to under the
effects
maybe we can finally modulate things so
that they're just right whatever that is
i would say whatever that is is to
preserve the maximum number of species
that we can
at this point to just be able to move
things back and forth and whatever we do
some of you were concerned about
ecological considerations believe me
this haunts me too and i'm still looking
for a good marine biologist to
collaborate with to be sure that we
pick the right kind of material and
right size range so that this will work
you know not have things not not mess up
whales as they're spouting when they
surface not mess up the base of our food
chain
all the algae there's a lot of life up
there in the arctic
um that under ice ecology is important
my thought is that the and you want
something that's not going to be an
energy hog to make so that you're
spewing more co2 in making it than
you're then you're compensating for
but the idea is if you can lever things
with a small amount of material
almost like a catalyst and regrow the
natural process
you can have less impact by allowing
more ice to stay
than you are having from all that ice
disappearing
so that's the thought and i have played
with a number of materials
over time i have this is my
fourth or fifth year of field testing
going on now small field tests
lakes once we went up to a lake in
canada where there was one of the
world's good
ice researchers there willing to
collaborate
and mostly we we keep going to the same
lake up in the sierra nevada mountains
where we're getting a lot of cooperation
from their water district
and the evolution has been went from
hollow glass spheres think of those 3m
hollow glass spheres used in a lot of
paints and building materials and such
but they tend to be very small so small
that they terrify
an asthmatic like me of hmm do we have a
respirable problem from the fines in
from the very fine particulate
okay well then we got to contain it well
by the time you've sewn things into very
fine mesh bags you know like a muslin or
even better
and you're going hmm that's going to
cost a lot and be
very hard to deploy went over to sheet
form materials to get
large enough areas that we could look at
how much was maintained
70 centimeter differences of
ice and snow preserved under these
materials when the melt came on this
lake
two winters ago which was great but boy
chasing sheets around any of you who
have sailed
know this far better than i knew going
into this chasing sheets around in a on
a lake with hundred mile an hour winds
which is a nice
i think of it as arctic.local it's a
nice audition
for what you were really trying to do
way farther out
miserably difficult not the right thing
to do tried some biodegradable modular
materials
not very content with those swim back to
low cost flushing
low-cost floating glass in mesh bags and
i wanted to
just pass around to you a little sample
of what i'm talking about
so humor me it's always nice to make
things a little bit real
this is a form of glass that's made out
of recycled glass
it's pretty inexpensive it's the stuff
that leads to that one cent per square
meter estimate
and i've left myself many barriers
just and i'll start another one on that
end
and we'll hope the glasses don't break
they seem to have
a tendency to try to crack
and if that's so bring them up quick
before they leak all over your stuff
what i like about this stuff is you can
get it in various grain sizes
and it's pretty inexpensive and you can
imagine
containing it in things which you can
get anywhere
i left the house this morning before
another meeting
having forgotten to bring my little
sample material with me
oh this must be driving a soundtrack
nuts
but you can imagine containing them in
fundamentally the kind of material
you've got in a mesh laundry bag and so
you can pass that around too
and that's basically what we've got
although a little higher tech
on our lake right now i found an x
military diver who makes very you know
bags like that out of stronger materials
with
really strong velcro closures and that's
what's sitting there right now
so simple um so this was the deployment
of course we keep on
evolving our instrumentation package
while we do this and we're doing it with
all volunteers so it's people who
okay i'm in between all my business
trips i can i can spend a little time
with you leslie to try to get some time
pictures here you know things like that
but interesting work
um here's this year's deployment that we
just put out trying to catch the freeze
this time we want to see how these
materials act
as the lake freezes and you know people
who worry
about rogue billionaires those are some
of the words at some of these workshops
trying to deploy a stratospheric sulfate
aerosol deployment
you know because it's within their or or
some other technique you know like
flinging the iron
because they could and who could stop
them and it would be sneaky
i've got to say something like what
we're doing the entire neighborhood
stops by while we're out there and they
come and they ask what's going on and
they stare at our little platform out on
the lake
it is anything but secret um
and that's what it's looking like right
now it's sitting there peacefully on the
lake right now it's got a couple
different kinds of mesh bags and a
couple different sizes of these
materials in them and part of why i was
in washington
recently was to say you know for things
like this that are low impact that we
clean up our mess we go back to the same
lake year after year you know we put our
toys away when we're done basically
um really could have a different kind of
regulation than some of these other
things that are more irreversible that
you know that people are talking about
and so that's that's part of the
question and we've got a really
our instrumentation guys really work
hard we've got um
cameras it's our best platform yet we're
hoping for some really good data to come
out of this
cameras pyranometer you know you want to
look at sunlight coming in
reflection back mass balance as far as
you can get it for how much
is it changing what's your effect of
albedo
how much is it changing how quickly snow
and ice
go away and such and we found just
floating these before the
instrumentation platform was quite
finished floating some of these bags
right at the shore
we found that with the small snowfall
and ice freezing that had happened
already and then it went through another
melt cycle
think of it as being like a geneticist
working with fruit flies
there's a certain area up in the sierras
certain area of time
certain where you can go through a few
cycles we were finding that we were
retaining more
more snow and ice on top and underneath
these materials
than on open water where you can imagine
if snow's falling in it's just melting
right away if it's not
if it's not below freezing yet so very
interesting
a big win would be to build back ice
that doesn't melt as quickly
in the arctic when you are re-freezing
after a big melt
you tend to make thin first year ice
that has a very low
albedo it hasn't had a chance yet to
build
back all of those imperfections that
allow it to be so reflective it starts
out as kind of that glare
ice so we're trying to look at this and
see can we build back multi-year ice to
start with
and the rough cost magnitude you know
here's what things look like as they're
melting these days and here's our
materials as they're
out there the idea is
that we've got a higher albedo and
depending what size spheres i'm actually
passing around spheres that are larger
even than this because they're working
with my laundry bags
these are the kinds of coverage costs
you get from just that material
not from putting it in a bag not from
getting it there
and and deploying it so it will
certainly be a higher cost than that but
you know not ferociously awful
if we could get away with the smallest
and cheapest thing and no containment
and i don't know that that's a good idea
how do you undeploy it then
but if if we decided that was net
benefit ecologically
500 million per year if you wanted to
rebuild one of those historic
old ice melts you know 50 000 square
kilometers a year which is dauntingly
big
um you know we could afford that if we
decided we wanted to
and so that's that's what i'm trying to
establish you've been curious about what
i'm doing that's
one thing but it's important beyond the
work that i can do
myself there and and my volunteer team
and let me acknowledge
a recent volunteer who has added to the
team
susan i mean this is just it's amazing
how
a team can grow along with you
on this sort of thing but beyond
anything that we can do
and janie's been help you know the way
this thing grows is is gratifying you
are not alone that's for sure
but beyond that getting the word out and
getting other people to think about what
they can do
is so key so i look at this class as one
of the things that i'm trying to do
for climate and i'm really hoping you
guys
got some information out of it that will
be helpful to you
i'm finally saying yes uh when people
are asking me to participate in national
policy debate
i don't look at myself as that kind of a
person but
you know what if you're being asked and
it's important you say yes
so i'm going to go in february to a
panel on sea ice management
at columbia i just a few weeks ago was
at this wilson center for international
scholars workshop
on soft geoengineering that is should we
regulate it differently than some of
these other methods
i got to attend this one back in april
that i mentioned to you where the
aircraft companies are telling you how
inexpensive it would be
to get stratospheric sulfate aerosols up
there
in a reasonable amount so just all kinds
of interesting ways to get the word out
and
this is you know i'm presenting this as
kind of a role model
if you want to do something i think
these are some of the things you want to
consider
what's the work you yourself can do and
how can you amplify it
and then i'm giving um the first
scientific talk that i'm getting to give
i've given some general interest talks
on this
um at the agu meeting on friday so
that'll be
wonderful you know these 20 or 30 000
climate scientists up there although i
have no illusions how big my
audience will be since it's early in the
morning the morning after the big
conference
banquet so
but whatever two or three people are in
there to talk to me this will be great
and we've got a journal article in
progress so once you do some work
try to get the word out too and try to
get it out so that people can give you
feedback about
have you considered this hazard have you
considered that peril have you
considered this experimental site
it all matters if you want to hear
although you will not hear
i don't think more information than
you've heard today but if you want to
come and say hi and listen again i'm
going to be giving a talk
locally just to a general audience
for for people 12 and up and this is
part of our attempt to raise funds for
this
so that you know that helps because
certainly the instrumentation and stuff
takes some money um so
having gone through ice 911 having gone
through kind of geoengineering
and kind of a class i want to return to
the class and then i think i'm talking
fast enough we're going to be able to
have time for some questions if you've
got them which is good
so this is a recycled slide from the
first lecture
just i think i would like to leave you
with the thought of what can you do
with climate challenges you know move
move past drink in
how bad it is certainly spend some time
feeling just paralyzed with this is
really bad
we've got a huge problem to solve but
get past that
and then what can you do about it and so
i loved what john coomie wrote those
those quotes that we started with right
our choices for response or mitigation
adaptation and suffering
okay so let's let's try to work on the
first two
um the problem's big it's urgent it's
misunderstood
new ventures if you've got something
great
the world needs it you know you've got
opportunity
you may have a big idea you're wondering
should i bother
you might think about it you might go
contact rex northern go go enter it at
the cleantech open you know there's a
lot of ways to get things out
and it takes a lot of us doing a lot of
things i think this is a huge
problem it is truly a planetary problem
um business needs environmentalists and
environmentalists need business
yeah it's true and so i wanted to end
with if you remember that video we
showed at the very beginning
that youtube video if you don't remember
it you can get the
the link from the slide set from the
first lecture
you can keep it simple and have a huge
impact right what could be simpler than
a plastic bottle
filled with water and a teeny bit of
bleach through a hole in somebody's roof
to bring
light inside during the daytime it can
be simple
to be wonderful and so think about what
more you need to learn
and what you will try the resources are
all around
and again just my parting shot yep that
is the parting shot i hope this has
helped you get a start on all this and
i'd love to hear
what your adventures are your climate
related adventures are
over time okay thanks a lot and
questions you must have more questions
even though you said
thank you very much
what else anybody yes
saying that the arctic
contributes about 20 percent to the
climate
that's what the old models were saying
and yeah
so you're addressing a 20 problem
basically so in the worst case things go
south and
we we have to use this solution it
doesn't solve at all
we're going to need some more right
absolutely that's
that's one thing that actually kind of
comforted me starting it you know that
that whole moral repugnance thing was
if people got wind of this and if it
were working would they use it as an
excuse to open up more coal mines it's
like
not if they're listening you know
because it it
won't solve the whole thing but 20 is a
pretty good chunk to take on
i guess the follow up on that would be
um
could this be extended to use in the
open ocean
or at equatorial latitudes
for instance or template latitudes just
for the albedo effect in general without
worrying about
ice formation and stuff possibly and in
fact there's a
there are other methods people are
looking at for brightening water too
did i give you guys that paper i gave
you the soft geoengineering paper
which would lead you to it there's a
there's another technique
being uh worked on where uh russell
seitz
is injecting bubbles into water he calls
it bright water
and that's a really interesting thing
there i look at it as kind of two
uh sides of the same coin you know you
can use energy to be squirting bubbles
into something and then when you stop
adding energy it stops and so you you
know you've got a reversible
effect right there but you have to keep
adding energy
or you can put a material which you know
you've done your best to to make it a
benign material
and just let it stay out there and not
have to add any energy
you know but but you could do the same
thing with both you could cool water
that way
and in fact yeah this this works well
for cooling water
i've tested it that was one of the sets
of starting tests i did so yes
yes it's worth doing it's you know cool
roofs is another
um how many sides of my coin can i have
here but another side of the coin
that people talked about of just
painting as many roofs or
or having um your pavements being
white to also reduce the urban heat
island effect they call it to
to help to brighten things and cool
things off and that has a big effect
can you do it then with with bodies of
water
and and will you be not harming anything
by brightening it you are going to
reduce how much sunlight is coming
down in in the arctic i like the idea of
rebuilding
ice itself because i'm trying to
bootstrap a process that
has been that way for a long time you
know these glaciers that are melting now
are 300
000 years old is is what chasing ice is
saying
so that's a big change and so i'm trying
to put it
back you know so that everything that's
evolved for that
gets to see what it's used to again but
if you're now
brightening water in areas where it
hasn't been bright before you're going
to have some other untoward
effect eventually maybe you know what's
the
who gets to decide this stuff of what's
the worst effect
getting things warmer or having this
slight darkening underneath your water
column
i sure hope it's not me you know my my
vision
all along and and what people are hoping
for is there will be
international government bodies or ngos
that
you know or the un who's making these
decisions it's not just
lone researchers deciding well
because we have to here let's fling this
you know like
like that iron guy um does that help
answer it enough
yeah yeah it should be considered did
you
on that note is there is there a
governing body right now that sort of is
taking that role is it just
the ipcc or the u.n or yeah
they look into it you know they until
so recently when things got so
dramatically
different on on ice melt in particular
because it's something that
you know people for finding it hard to
ignore
people really shunned the whole idea
they didn't want to think about it
there is the the royal society came out
with uh
so uk came out with a report starting to
look at what geoengineering governance
would be
i don't think the us is doing much about
it except there's these couple workshops
this year
that i got to go to so you know the
conversation is starting
but um it it has yet to
to happen and the arctic facing nations
i'm thinking are
the people that i would be talking to
most but
we haven't been there yet it's hard to
find a route there because in part
the there is growing you know it really
hasn't
been there yeah
it's it's on the edge anybody else
yes kind of question i guess on
thermal transfer in your experimentation
you've laid these on open water too not
just
does the area under your blankets
freeze as quickly as the water next to
them
i can't tell yet because i wouldn't
expect i would expect these things to be
insulating and i know you're allowing
for evaporative
well and you're also allowing if you
look at the samples making their way
around these things
are very porous and so they are getting
saturated quickly too
so while there will be some thermal
insulation from the material itself
you've got a continuous column actually
of water coming through
i think what's making them float are the
isolated
air pockets in there so it will have
some
but it won't be as much as if you had a
continuous sheet
i think because you've got
you've got a lot of water there but we
don't have the granularity so to speak
to resolve that yet
we we need we need more tests and you
really
want freezing to happen you want
freezing yes you do
and bouncing the
incoming radiation back out at least
keeps from heating
but if it's already warm water and
you're insulating it then that would
tend to inhibit i would think the
freezing effect
well we'll get to see um certainly in
the initial freeze
that we saw with you know just a couple
weeks worth
the wish i had that photo with me
what we were seeing was that the ice was
preferentially growing to some extent
on the sheets over what was around it
which was really gratifying
what we could see from the top yeah what
we could see on top
one of the initial things that i thought
about with this was that if you had
a raft of something out on
out on open ocean and you were snowing
that you were going to be retaining snow
on the raft and maybe bridging if you
had particles bridging them together
to make a new platform we're on open
ocean it could be snowing in there and
be melting into it
right you've got a little bit of help
there but the arctic doesn't have a lot
of precipitation historically so it's
well that better not be the main thing
you're counting on
but but it does seem to work
um i'm also happy to take any questions
on
career paths and how on earth you
network into climate too because that
seemed to be the tenor of a lot of the
questions people were submitting online
but maybe i covered that enough too
you first then you yeah i got two
questions one is how healthy is it to do
to be spreading so a lot of sulfate into
the atmosphere and
and the second question is if
the main issue is the amount of co2 in
the atmosphere why not just work on
carbon
on carbon dioxide reducing methods like
planting trees or algae farms or
something of that nature
okay two very good questions um the
sulfate
i have to say i have an emotional
reaction of my own too
because i carry around an inhaler for
asthma i know
sulfates are bad um the people who
like so that's a gut reaction i will
never get past
um but the people who like that as an
idea
will point out that the amount that they
want to put in the atmosphere
in the troposphere first it's the
troposphere so it's far away from us
far enough far away from where we're
breathing um you know until it comes
down
in precipitation they're saying so i'm
hearing sulfuric acid probably
eventually
got other issues with um but they uh
they talk about also besides that it's
far away from our lungs when you're
shooting it up there that it's at far
lower levels than we had
historically for pollution so in my
youth in the 70s for instance
we had far more sulfate
pollution in the air than we have now
and people have actually
found that as we are surmising that as
we cleaned up
a lot of that industrial pollution it
actually probably spiked
our warming a little bit because we got
rid of that anti-greenhouse gas so the
people who want to do this stratospheric
injection are saying
the levels we're putting up there are
lower than what we used to have as
pollution
and it's far away from from us breathing
so that's the
that's their thought um and the second
question you asked was uh if carbon
dioxide's the main issue
then why not just work on reducing
carbon dioxide
right so people do but it's not
everything that people are doing the co2
levels are
increasing far more than than anything
they've managed to do so far these
carbon
sequestration techniques and carbon
scrubbing and carbon removal techniques
are really
important too it just doesn't seem to be
enough
yet um look into the gsap things because
they've done a substantial amount of
things on carbon sequestration and it's
right here on campus
you can get to it pretty easily but yes
absolutely people need to work on that
as part of why i find
guys like the electric catalysis people
really interesting so will chua and
thomas jaramillo
because they are taking in a really
interestingly
energetic way right you could maybe do
this with
with photovoltaic well not quite
photovoltaics but solar powered
to allow you to convert co2 into useful
other things it's really pretty neat and
sort of avoid the problem that way too
the problem people have with scrubbing
co2 of course
is the concentrations are teeny and in
fact you know about what the
concentrations are what are we at right
now 350
no we're over that aren't we 350 ppm
390 ppm now um so that's a pretty small
amount to try to scrub so then people
who are trying to scrub at the
stacks of say coal plants well that's
that's more rewarding right you've got a
higher
concentration there but still it's a
pretty diffuse and pretty difficult
transport problem so are you going to
spend more energy
and thus generate more co2 than than you
gained but it's it's it's key if you've
got the right technology it's really key
the world will beat a path to your door
trees yeah yeah i mean just yeah
they matter and to stop deforestation
matters a lot yeah so i agree
it doesn't seem to be enough somehow
i did a lot of work with algae well good
and um
one thing that i thought a lot about and
you have to keep in mind is
when you're talking about trees and
deforestation is i mean stopping that is
really important but when you're talking
about trees and algae
the carbon cycle is so short that
i mean you're you're taking carbon in
you're sinking it but then
the trees and the algae die and they you
know
so it's not like a permanent sink
whereas the fossil fuels that we're
burning
that's really really really old carbon
so
just saying oh well we'll we'll get some
plants and things
to to sink this carbon into well they're
going to die and decompose
so you really need to think about the
scale of the carbon cycle you're looking
at
so we decided it wasn't super
worthwhile what we were looking at
it's important and sobering yeah what
what's the
average age do you know you sound like
you might of the fossil deposits that
we're
using are we using a hundred thousand
years worth of stuff
millions of years yeah that's hard to
make up for in a year of tree planting
huh
die pretty quickly so
yeah i read somewhere that on tree
growth and carbon sequestration
it was i think of a forest of about a
hundred years
or newer was still sort of net positive
in
sequestrating carbon but after about 100
years or so then it's sort of an unusual
balance of
new growth versus decaying uh and that
particular article was suggesting that
we should chop down trees and sing them
to the bottom of the ocean
but um
terrible ideas you know quick digestion
and release methane instead
yeah it's methane i didn't even talk
about permafrost but of course as the
ice melts
people are becoming so alarmed because
methane plumes are appearing in the
ocean and methane is a far
worse greenhouse gas than co2 so that's
the other
sort of unpredictable amount that's
poised to hit us as well and it's it's
another huge concern to try to stop or
slow down
ice melt if you can you've had a burning
question for a while sir
i was just wondering if you've had a
chance to look at
how long your glass beads will last in a
freeze
freeze thaw cycle i
not yet oh yeah and if they went away
after a year
but we're still incorporated in the ice
to some extent that would probably still
be
sure they'd be fine yeah um one of the
things i worry about is and i've seen
this over time
now having had a bunch of them just out
in a
wading pool over over a long time
and water coming in from rain and then
evaporating and you know
kids and cats attacking it and stuff
that some of them are sinking after a
while
and so but it's it's the order of many
months
but it's hmm these may not be around
floating
for so long is that a problem maybe
that's good you're basically making your
floating sand into more like sand sand
sinking to the bottom but again the life
cycle
questions the effects of any you know
well what if you had a light dusting of
this on your seafloor
is that going to be an issue for
something living down there all this
stuff has to be looked at
and the collaboration you know i'm
serious if you folks know any good
marine biologists who want to
collaborate i
that's a word i will keep putting out
because we don't have one yet and we
need it
anything else
okay it has been oh and we're at 203 so
the timing is terrific
it has been such a pleasure getting to
know you folks thank you so much
your summaries your questions reading
those have just made my week time after
time
and thank you i wish you all great luck
so let me say to you
thank you
you